vemos que el gobierno savor DiNozzo
porque para mais negeri SE NOS acaba de
nuestra vida estamos viviendo neuf en
mexico is at a breaking point drug
violence forced disappearances
government complicity there's a sense of
lawlessness here and from everyone we
spoke to it was clear something's got to
change what's happening since 2006
25,000 people have been forcibly
disappeared and that's just the number
of the government acknowledges zoso my
cozy hose k1000 desaparecer owned a
trenta de agosto de la ley goes below
cho cabo de appreciate Ron's y no sabe o
una vez SI alvida uno de su vida de tu
trabajo de tu Familia olvida solo por la
edad de que en contra de tu familia
every week padre of scar opens the doors
of his church to over 300 members of the
committee of the other disappeared of
iguala a group that organizes to find
their missing loved ones casi toda son
iguales vs gaara Dora's me desaparece
ii-era na mijo y el sello secuestrar o
numero peau de personas nunca NOS PD
Erin rescate a desde entonces no se
donde esta es lo mas como the
devastating number of disappearances
coincides with Mexico's nationwide
crackdown on drug cartels that began in
2006 the military has become a key
player in the country's drug war and law
student Melissa Zamora sees this
presence as a problem she's been active
in groups seeking justice for the
disappeared ESO es unica response alia
del estado zal estado ha sido quien a
considerado como esta hecha de seguridad
Nacional sakali her seat Oh Alice cadres
a la policia federal mo lucre la un
monton de investigaciones y ESO y habla
de un contexte valencia general azada
dad militarization says activist Jorge
Romero has led to high levels of
corruption faster
msoc oddo con la violencia los últimos
des amis es que exacerbate hola mucho de
altura de porque si ability a la policía
a las fuerzas armadas para hacer cosas
que antes no podemos he says this kind
of abuse of power is rarely investigated
or punished cuando in pune dad es decir
no a fiscal k investigative no i ah
hence investigador a campus de iniciar
un proceso para analyze our los
problemas en los actos a corruption
basicamente toes invoices and corruption
has led to mistrust in Mexican politics
as a whole una FATA salud de confianza
en el sistema politico crow en todos
novellas a SI NOS vamos mi velco develop
orator no see conf en los partidos
políticos yo mi opinión me perspectiva
tambien que tengo es que mexico y genera
el pais de esta secuestrado por los
partidos políticos yo pienso que yo son
los culpable de todo esto que esta
pasando por que yo somos k in ponen a
los candidatos que ellos tienen no digan
que el pueblo Alicia what can be done in
the face of a cycle of violence and
corruption Jorge Melissa are part of por
eso propongo a project that asked
Mexicans to suggest changes for their
country by way of postcard the activists
were overwhelmed with 8,000 responses
that they consolidated into 10 concrete
proposals es esta mas los de
las diez batallas nicorette con el tema
la cancion con el tamalero denise moon
scenarios con el tema tener acceso
allocation a pura yeah salud con calidad
konkani des des una perspectiva HSE
manos they say that elected officials
are beginning to respond to pressure
from civil society groups es OU konnen
Esperanza Francesca no quisiera que
baby steps baby steps makes sense but
how much longer can Mexicans afford to
wait for their leaders to grow up
you